last question today what is the last
question today why aren't you verified
on Twitter Gil wants to know I don't
have an answer for you I have submitted
a Twitter verification request not once
but twice I know that there are many
media hosts with fewer followers than me
who are verified there are uh media
hosts with much smaller shows that are
verified and I've submitted it twice at
the direction of the audience and I've
not been verified either time I get a
message from Twitter saying uh
unfortunately we're not able to verify
you right now you can reapply in a month
and i'm scheduled to do that again i
guess in about two weeks but i have no
idea why i can't seem to get verified on
Twitter I don't know that it's a big
deal but the kids these days email in
and they're like David you should really
get verified you can have that blue
check box box check mark and sounds
pretty cool but I seem unable to be able
to get it done well if it makes you feel
any better I have about 30 followers and
you're also not verified I'm also yeah
if anybody has advice I don't know that
you can really get a verification
campaign going I think it's just a
matter of me requesting verification
they the only thing I could do
differently is they asked for sort of
like links that show who you are so I
put in there the link to my wiki page I
put in there the link to the show wiki
page a link to the show website and a
couple of press mentions about the show
maybe I'm putting in the wrong stuff I
don't know what else I could do uh but
if anybody knows about this by all means
please let me know fantastic bonus show
for you today I'm so out of time I can't
even tell you what is on today's bonus
show but what I can tell you for sure
believe me folks is that today's bonus
show is fantastic and that you can sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
I'll speak to you then